[Music]
it shows like real life kids and what
things that are happening with kids
today Christina was just 15 for her
first ET interview we're showing a
different way to deal with things she
was excited about her role as a
detective's daughter and already a pro
but can you recognize Christina here
she's 12 years old in this 1983 Barbie
commercial later she guest starred on
shows like Charles in Charge
[Music]
crispy Crunchies 21 Jump Street when did
you get here and when are you leaving
and family ties with Michael J fox
okay but her big breakout came in 1987.
as Cali Bundy look what they want me to
wear in my next verminator commercial
when I first read the script I I
couldn't believe that they were going to
put something like that on television
what a shame
a body like that and not a brain in his
head
I'm really happy being on the show
something different you know if I was to
be on any kind of sitcom I would
definitely want it to be something so
beyond I don't think anybody in the
business side that we would get past 13
and here we are 100 and but we're on 104
now actually Married with Children ran
for 11 Seasons Christina was reportedly
making over 125 thousand dollars per
episode I think we've all just stayed
together because I mean this is a family
this is a group of friends and I don't
think that any one of us would would
leave you know it would pay us too much
damn money it would be stupid there's
that too during breaks and married with
Children Christina starred in movies we
could only afford the Necessities Kenny
including the cult classic Don't Tell
Mom the Babysitter's Dead just an
All-American kind of girl you know who's
just going through all these these
changes and these problems and growing
up and going into an adult situation
everything like that so it's a lot
different I mean I refuse to play
another Kelly Bundy role I think that
it's you know I'm burnt out on that one
Christina hosted SNL in 1993. you know I
think you need a hat with that two years
later she put her dance training to work
as one of the founding members of The
Pussycat Dolls
which debuted at The Viper Room on the
Sunset Strip I actually kick and scream
and fight about the costumes sometimes
because you know things are out and
hanging out and everywhere Christina won
an Emmy in 2003 for guest starring on
Friends an episode called the one with
Rachel's other sister you just think
you're so perfect
in your your small apartment I never
told them any of them this and I had
never really seen friends
probably one of the only people they're
like come to your friends I was like
great and then I get there and I'm like
well whose baby is this they're like
I was like fantastic fantastic it was a
really really fun week the statue was an
added bonus and
um that was really cool you know to just
go in and have fun and then someone's
like that was you did good having fun
speaking of fun in 2004 Christina
starred in Anchorman I said
your hair
looks stupid
opposite Will Ferrell I think that this
little movie's gonna hold up on its own
for us it was really about the
experience doing this movie was the best
time that any of us would ever have so
it's really whatever happens happens
the comedy was a surprise hit making
more than 90 million dollars at the box
office in 2013 a sequel you need to shut
your mouth how is this to be reunited
with your cast mate oh I'm so happy to
be with them I mean I just like it makes
me happy just to see them all here and
here we are 10 years later and it's a
whole other Vibe it's going to be news
team again we're all together
Christina hit the roller rink as one of
Jessica Simpson's besties in the 2006
video public Affair the next year she
returned to TV with Samantha Who we've
had sex before haven't we Christina's
character is forced to start life over
after a hit and run accident leaves her
with amnesia when you first saw the
script and heard about the project what
were your thoughts were you like I just
thought it was written really well this
is a real show with real moments and and
the funny has to come out of you know
the the tragedy of her own existence you
really are like you have this you're
like a great comedic actress indeed you
kind of build it up over the years no no
what I'm saying is like maybe you won't
get the you know people won't say oh you
get the love that you deserve for that
but you've had time to kind of build up
those comedic shops huh yeah well you
know I I had 11 years of practice with a
bunch of really funny people it's about
learning what makes you laugh as well
this show which has been really great is
that the character of Sam is she's got a
lot of my weird quirk and things the
show lasted only two seasons but
Christina received two Emmy nominations
for outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series it's a show that I really loved
more than anything in the world and a
part and a crew and a cast that was like
the stars were aligned so it's
bittersweet Christina was back on the
big screen with bad moms in 2016. I can
make life
and your dirty little children
do you understand me your character is
an uptight type a mom in the movie is
that close to home for you no no no no
no no no
little girl I am going to destroy you
winter is coming I like to think of
myself as like a type a hippie mom where
I have like my daughter's life is sort
of is very like scheduled out
um because I needed to stay that way but
I'm also like about like let's just go
with the flow man and oh those two sides
of myself fight a lot but here's what is
incredible about Christina behind the
scenes she was bravely tackling serious
health battles including breast cancer
she was 36 when she had the double
mastectomy that saved her life were you
still shocked when they told you hey
because you had been so ridiculous in my
mind yeah I lost my mind yeah um I still
sometimes lose my mind you know six
years later you just go well you look
down and you you are constantly you have
a daily reminder of everything that
you've gone through you know is there a
message that you feel is important to
share with women related to your journey
people always say it early detection
there are women now in their 20s getting
breast cancer and now we're seeing that
happening to 18 year old girls getting
breast cancer I mean I started getting
mammograms at 30 but I remember my
doctor said you know
the the mammograms are not working for
you because you're too dense and so
we're going to do an MRI and it was with
that MRI that I found cancer years
before a mammogram would have
Christina started her own Foundation to
make MRIs affordable for women Christina
you there's hardly anything you could do
that's more valuable than that because
people simply don't get tested I know
sometimes these things get thrown at you
for a reason my reason is to have a
voice then last year during the final
season of taping her Netflix series dead
to me Christina learned she had Ms the
TV role was cathartic she said because
like her character her emotions brought
tears
last month Christina made a triumphant
return to the spotlight at the Hollywood
Walk of Fame
at times the actress who had been using
a cane was physically supported by her
former TV mom Katie Seagal Christina
described the event as a full circle
moment I've had a really interesting
life
started
waiting in line to see the first Star
Wars on this very Street at that very
theater and looking at these things
going who are these people what did they
do did they do something right did they
do something wrong whatever it is I want
one
I want one
and I was five years old
so um this day means more to me than you
could possibly imagine
[Music]